make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
it's finally here yes it is what's going
on rob cor what's going on everybody
who's part of the rob poor today we are
covering more deceased we are covering
the wrath of black Adam now what we
talked about in the last video that we
did where we discussed this whole idea
of the euros at World's End we had the
main DC story and then these kind of
fill in the gaps between each of the
main issues one of the things we talked
about the last video we haven't been
given an explicit timeline right so we
don't know exactly when this takes place
we just know it takes place before
certain characters were affected and
before certain events unfolded right so
we can just kind of roll with that and
let it be as it may but the cool thing
is we pick up in the palace of conduct
with none other than Black Adam and the
reason why is because within minutes of
the anti-life equation basically
touching down on earth as is told to us
the Black Adam immediately shut down the
internet and conduct and while under any
normal circumstance that would be
considered an act of oppression and this
instance is an act of saving right
suicide is a good gun it's better to
have one and not need one and a need one
and not have one is one of these these
these weird things where how its viewed
changes on this situation the other half
the other half of this visit of course
he immediately takes out you know some
of the individuals who were in the lab
controlling the internet basically like
they're taken out and then black Adam
makes this wildly I wouldn't say so much
impressive decision but this decision
that really I hadn't considered before
Black Adam basically analyzes the entire
city off conduct right realizing that
people are being infected left and right
and basically says I have a choice here
I can take my time and try to save
survivors and save as many as I can but
that number is going to go down
exponentially relative to how long it
takes me to save someone he looks at
that and says that if he tries to go
through and save people forever you've
one person he saves one hundred people
will fall or he can just kill all those
who are infected just like that like
sweep through like a plague and he goes
with the latter choice he sweeps through
his own city and annihilates every
single person who's infected using his
power now on the surface this looks like
the most hardcore thing that a person
could do but one thing that you have to
understand when it comes to Black Adam
is that his loyalty is to the people of
conduct first and foremost and so it's
not with a light heart that he's just
like finally my chance to annihilate all
these people it's not really like that
right the reality of this is he's being
tasked with going through wiping out
people that he loves he'll do whatever
he needs to do to protect his kingdom of
conduct
you would wage war against the Justice
League he would kill every hero on earth
if he had to but he'll do whatever he
needs to do in order to make sure his
kingdom stay safe right as one of these
these really really cool and dedicated
aspects of his character but the issue
with this is that empty in the end he is
annihilating his own people and those
individuals who were who were not
infected or watching it all happen and
so from there what it does is it
switches over to him basically having a
having a conversation with his advisor
and it's kind of this idea of oh my god
you know he's basically going through
and he's literally killing people off
right like annihilating people and so
what it does is it switches over to
essentially what kind of looks like the
silhouette of an infected Superman and
then you have all these people who were
there or at least a guy in a son who
were there who were being surrounded by
all these infected right there were at
least a guy a woman you know and things
are kind of you know in a state of
pandemonium and so what it does is it
basically leads to us realizing this is
before Superman is infected that you
have wonder woman who who grabs this
young guy and his son along with another
guy who survived and kind of wished them
away and it's really it's almost kind of
like this juxtaposition right where you
have Black Adam who's just sweeping
through his entire country like a like a
plague like he on everybody who's
infected with the anti-life equation and
doing it with with absolute swiftness
and with no mercy whatsoever what you
have a super manic company who are
trying to save who they can where they
can't and it's kind of one of these
funny things right because it asks so
really interesting question here which
we'll talk more about that here in the
quote here in a minute but one of the
cool questions that it asks here is our
Superman and end company really are they
really benefiting anybody right because
if we look at that ratio we just kind of
go with it as an absolute truth that for
every one person they save that 100
people will fall that what they could be
doing is just flying around and
eradicating anybody with the anti-life
equation and then basically saving more
of humanity and so in essence what
they're doing by making it making the
choice they made was to actually
sacrifice human lives in order to save
human lives right so they're sacrificing
probably more lives than they're saving
in order to keep people alive they're
actually doing more harm than good
by trying to be good guys it's a really
really cool comparison and it's a really
cool juxtaposition now again that that
requires us to make certain assumptions
on our part but what you end up having
of course is this before we end up
seeing that Martian Manhunter is
infected and Martian Manhunter basically
traveling around and kind of surveying
the land and so on comes to the
realization that conduct is still safe
right conduct doesn't really seem to
have any indication of infection now
what they don't seem to know is that
black out of white
anybody who had the infection but at the
end of the day Superman Martian
Manhunter and Wonder Woman show up on
their doorstep and Black Adam greets
them and says stumped and this is par
for the course for his character right
to show out show up here to greet the
superheroes and then say no further
right you do not come into my country
you don't set a foot on the soil of my
country until I tell you it's okay but
what you end up having here is Superman
who basically says hey look man we're
here to essentially seek asylum is
really what this is right what we're
looking for it for conduct because
you're because you're uninfected we're
looking for conduct to be a place where
those individuals who were uninfected
can find refuge where they can find
safety and this is kind of a smart move
by by by by Black Adam depending on how
you look at it right he looks at
Superman and says you can tear through
these monsters faster than the speed of
sound you can reduce the infected to
ashes with a glance but will you with
all your great power can you destroy the
infected Superman and Superman's
response is no I cannot but if you open
conduct to survivors we can help protect
your borders and basically make sure
that everything's okay and it is funny
because black kind of responds it says
so much power and yet so weak and one of
them is response is compassion is not
weakness this creates an amazing debate
right list this see that's why I love
reading Tom Taylor right Tom Taylor is
so good at taking situations and then
juxtaposing them and then basically
asking us which one do you pick like how
do you stand on this and it's an
interesting scenario right because I
would say that black Adam actually did
more to protect more of his people by
just mercilessly wiping out individuals
who had the anti-life equation then the
super heroes have the issue that you
have with the superhero community to say
for example that that Superman and
Wonder Woman and all the different
superheroes who are left alive say okay
what we're gonna do is we're going to
split up and we're gonna focus on each
individual city right like each of a
vidual state or what-have-you basically
some territory that's comparable to the
size of conduct and basically we're
gonna race to see how many people we can
save what's gonna happen here is you're
gonna have black Adam just racing
through and killing everybody with the
anti-life equation on the other half
you're gonna have Superman and company
flying to a location seeing survivors
whisking down to get those survivors
pick them up fly them to a safe location
fly back and then just keep repeating
that process right while that's
happening you have all these people who
were in varying other locations who were
either confronted with those who are
infected with the anti-life equation
most likely dying or somebody's hiding
in Bunker's waiting to be saved in which
case they'll be fine but essentially
what Superman and company are doing is
sacrificing lives in order to save lives
and that's what's so crazy about this is
because in the end their compassion is
their weakness because their compassion
is what's leading to an increase in the
death of people and that's why these
kind of conversations are so cool and
they're so good to have why because
there is no right answer here why there
is no definitive correct answer it's a
matter of perspective I'm curious of how
you guys see this right do you guys
think Superman and company are actually
making the situation worse by trying to
save lives through traditional means or
do you think black Adam did what should
have been done and just annihilated
everybody inside of his own country now
keep in mind we do know that because of
the end of the deceased book there is a
cure we don't know how to cure people
who have the anti-life equation yet but
we do know that a cure does exist
whether we'll see that manifest or not
we have no clue so the reality is if
Superman in them and they do like like
Adam did and wipe out those who are
infected you can't bring them back the
potential exists the possibility exists
to basically save them but is it worth
it right these are the cool kind of
questions that we're talking about and
so ultimately where you have Superman
and then basically saying hey look like
we'd be stronger together that kind of a
thing Black Adam ultimately rebukes him
and then sends them away but Tom Taylor
throws in kind of a caveat here right
this little nagging experience in the
mind of like Adam and the reason why is
because while Superman does have all
these powers and all these abilities the
one of the greatest abilities he has is
that he's persuasive he can convince
people that he's right now I'm kind of
on the fence about this right because I
still stand and I think the Black Adam
did the right thing but speaking with us
is live with his adviser and basically
asking the question do you believe I did
the right thing his advisors like well I
believe you did what was best for
conduct for there's one there's a
difference between doing what's best for
your country and doing what's right and
they're they're oftentimes not the same
thing like they're not mutually
exclusive and so because of that it's
interesting here in this this particular
situation because this leads to Black
Adam basically just reverting back to
his normal human form right and then you
know kind of going out among the streets
of conduct and seeing what's happening
and so because of that they end up
coming on a coming upon a few people who
actually like they recoil in fear at him
they're absolutely terrified of him and
the reason why is because they watched
on while he killed people who were
infected with the anti-life now the
truth of this is they didn't fully
understand what was going on all they
knew was that something happened people
started attacking them black out
killed them right but like at the same
time like did like Adam killed her their
sons and their daughters and their
brothers and their sisters and their
aunts and uncles and mothers and fathers
right they didn't know what had happened
to them they didn't know if they were
just kind of freaking out if they lost
their mind or something along those
lines but what they did know is they
were totally disintegrated in front of
them right like Adam right that's what
they knew and so what this does is it
basically leads up to a woman who's of
course sitting in front of the door and
with us this whole situation goes on
flight Adam starts to address or it says
hey are you all right and she's like you
know you're from the palace and the
response is yeah like like let's let's
let's talk like let's have a
conversation and this woman says well my
son's hurt he was hurt in the in in in
black Adams attack right she was hurt in
our Lord's attack and he's currently in
here and when the door opens up we end
up finding out he was not hurt in the
attack of black Adam he was hurt because
he's infected with the anti-life virus
and we're black out of walks in
immediately infected so black Adam is
now part of the anti-life army not only
that black Adam is gonna lead it well
that being said guys are gonna free this
video to an end if you are new here to
comment explain make sure you guys have
a sub button to become part of the rock
or if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a live spoilers and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]